Transcription: Mandy Vincent
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonsoir, bonsoir à tous.
Suite à notre rencontre
avec la Ressourcerie
située à l’entrée de la ville,
à « Jerecycle Parc »,
ça a été de réfléchir à comment
on pouvait valoriser nos actions,
nous, artistes et créateurs,
à travers une cause, le réemploi.
On a eu la chance d’avoir les portes
ouvertes de cette ressourcerie
et de choisir parmi les créateurs,
ce qu’on allait prendre comme
petits objets pour leur redonner vie,
leur redonner un sens
et petit à petit, créer une exposition.
Au départ, on était avec
vingt-sept, vingt-huit objets,
puis après, on est passé
à de plus en plus d’objets
pour atteindre la centaine et continuer
à recevoir de plus en plus d’artistes
et de techniques différentes.
Si, au départ, on était
avec des street artists,
de fil en aiguille,
on a eu beaucoup de chance
et on a eu des créateurs sur du carton,
des créateurs qui travaillaient
avec du textile, sur de la sidérurgie,
qui prenaient le temps de
dépiauter plein de petits objets
qui étaient vraiment obsolètes et
plus utilisables pour leur redonner vie
en recréant des sculptures métalliques
ou des choses d’assemblage.
C’est comme ça qu’on a vu
toute une série de personnes,
tous autant professionnels qu’amateurs,
venir compléter cette exposition.
On a eu la chance aussi petit à petit
de commencer à avoir des collectivités
qui se sont intéressées,
de plus en plus d’interaction
avec les gens.
Mais on a voulu pousser les choses
de manière plus grande et on s’est dit
qu’on allait faire tourner
notre projet autour d’une exposition.
Elle s’appelle le WalkTrip,
située dans le centre historique
de Clermont-Ferrand.
On a sélectionné quarante boutiques
et à chacune de ces boutiques,
qui ne sont pas nécessairement
liées au réemploi
ou à la cause de l’écologie,
on leur a dit : « Est-ce que ça
vous intéresserait d’héberger
une, deux ou trois œuvres dans vos locaux
afin de présenter
votre intérêt pour la cause,
mais aussi de permettre aux gens
de découvrir un peu l’exposition
et ce qu’on fait ? »
On a créé un plan.
Il y a un plan qui est distribué
à l’Office de tourisme
et un peu partout
sur la ville de Clermont.
On a pointé chacun de ces lieux
et de distribuer chacune de
ces œuvres pour sensibiliser à ça.
A côté, on met aussi en place des ateliers
et chaque fois, on met à disposition
des jeunes et des moins jeunes
des techniques pour
que ce ne soit pas nous,
mais tous les gens qui
soient acteurs eux-mêmes
et qui découvrent ce que l’on peut
faire pour redonner vie à des objets
et stopper ce choc de consommation,
de toujours se dire :
« Je vais racheter un neuf ».
Non, un objet qui a une seconde vie,
c’est un objet qui peut repartir
sur dix ans et bien plus.
Merci à vous.
(Applaudissements)